bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors d'abord c'est
peut-être une bonne nouvelle finalement
la nomination d'une personnalité
politique
si lille à la tête comme premier
ministre de la transition albert pahimi
padacke elle a déjà lui-même était
premier ministre et il faut le signaler
il a déjà été premier ministre il est
pendante pendant deux ans il est il fait
partie dans des arcanes du pouvoir de
monsieur feu débit feu débit monsieur
illisibilité un autocrate président
totalitaire il a été mon premier ministe
de 2016
la 2018 dans la volonté de concentration
des pouvoirs de la part de monsieur
idriss deby il a complètement donc
annulé donc fait disparaître ce poste de
premier ministre pour concentrer donc
pas seulement les pouvoirs politiques
mais aussi des pouvoirs militaires et
économiques et on
il a été nommé donc par son fils dans un
élan dynastique il est nommé par un fils
qui dans la charte dit bien que c'est
lui et non le premier ministre qui va
nommer les autres ministres qui peut
révoquer comme dans cette même charte
d'un militaire parce que le fils est un
militaire donc sans prérogatives de de
danon d'annuler de dissoudre la
constitution de dissoudre le
gouvernement de dissoudre l'assemblée
nationale
il est prévu dans la constitution que co
décède
d'après de du président c'est bien le
président de l'assemblée nationale qui
après le pouvoir donc là on ne peut
comprendre légitimement que les les
oppositions soit soit vent debout contre
ce type ce type d'attitude et de
décisions antidémocratiques
parce qu'une transition à ne peut l'être
que la transition avec une bonne partie
donc d opposition à dialogues d'une
définition de la stratégie redéfinir
quel type de transition et on ne peut
pas avoir à la tête d'un pays
un militaire arrivé au pouvoir par
l'intermédiaire d'un coup d'état parce
qu'il n'a aucune prérogative qui lui
permet d'être président aujourd'hui du
tchad et le président est une une
transition ou à l'intérieur de cette
charte de dit de 18 mois il y a à
l'intérieur un élément qui dit qu'ils
peuvent prorogée de 18 mois encore
supplémentaire donc cette période de
transition donc c'est trois ans donc on
peut comprendre les doutes la méfiance à
l'égard de cette transition
alors monsieur monsieur padacké et qui a
déjà été premier nice est un opposant
conte puis qu'on peut dire modéré qui
depuis un an et demi était opposant de
monsieur débit mais hélas bien dit et
qualifié d'ailleurs là cette personne
avec qui la travaillent c'est monsieur
idriss déby d'autocrates donc quelle est
la différence entre une autocratie du
père feu idriss déby d une autocratie
qui se remet en place par
l'intermédiaire de laquelle cette
question
c'est vrai qu'il ya cette question qui
concerne justement la mise en place d'un
conseil militaire alors que vous le
dites vous-même le pays dispose
d'institutions et que certaines pas dans
la norme d'une république
et puis une autre question aussi des
zones d'ombré autour de la mort d'idriss
deby qui est un fin stratège militaire
on le sait il est mort au front et c'est
ce qui pose beaucoup de questions sur
les circonstances justement de sa mort
idriss deby moi je sais que j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion justement l'interviewer le
pré l'ex le président défunt et il est
il a envoyé tout juste une colonne
justement pour tenter de secourir à
l'époque l'ex président centrafricain
françois bozizé donc il a il était
plutôt respectée dans la sous-région
comment sa mort comment expliquer sa
mort cesser ces zones d'ombré alors il
faut bien s'entendre sur le respect sur
la sous région c'est que les peuples de
la sous-région lui demandait comme une
demande alors à leur présidence d'avoir
une attitude démocratique des décisions
démocratiques
il avait il était à la tête d'une d'une
heure d'une arme du l'armée dit
puissante mais oh oh
mais assez fragile qui aussi commettez
des exactions
il faut savoir qu'à l'intérieur même de
cette armée il ya des personnes très
bien qui aujourd'hui conteste le fait
que son fils ait pris le pouvoir il ya
un schisme à l'intérieur du pouvoir
militaire ya un schisme à l'intérieur du
pouvoir politique même au sein même de
son parti parce que monsieur débit tout
tout
on parlait de lui comme quelqu'un qui
stabilisait la région maintenant ils
stabilisent l instabilité de la région
et l'instabilité de son pays
186e sur 489 pays au monde sur le
développement humain le système de santé
public le sentent
le système gère donc c'est important de
ton parlait justement on parle d'un
accrochage avec les rebelles des deux 2
du front pour l'alternance et la
concorde du tchad mais on parle aussi
d'un putsch des généraux
pour en revenir à la question initiale
oui alors la question initiale
j'y arrive c'est vrai que les conditions
de sa mort sont la version officielle
ces dons qui qu'ils soient morts au
front comme un soldat et non comme un
guerrier comme cela a été dit mais il
est un soldat qui est venu au front
devant des opposants est un mouvement de
résistance et non des rebelles viennent
tropicalisation du terme pour certaines
géographies certaines personnes sur
cette planète c'est bien il a bien en
face de lui des opposants est un
mouvement de résistance ou à l'intérieur
du fac qu'il n'y a aucun terrorisme il y
a aucun extremis il ya des personnes
comme lui autant il y a trente ans il
est arrivé au pouvoir dans un mouvement
similaire de résistance par rapport à
celui qu'il a donc détrôné avec qui il a
travaillé d'ailleurs monsieur hissène
habré qui aujourd'hui dans les geôles au
sénégal pour les crimes qu'il a
perpétrés en tant que président donc il
y a
une confusion un flou sur qu'est ce qui
a conduit à la mort de détresse des
billets à la version officielle mais il
ya d'autres versions il ya aussi des
fêtes news des thèses conspirationnistes
et complotistes mais on voit bien que il
souvent il se mettait en scène sur les
théâtres de conflits mais en tant que
président c'était quand même assez
risqué d'aller sur le front même si
c'était un soldat aguerri il ya toujours
le risque d'être blessé ou des tués et
là notamment il était entraîné des
opposants qui aujourd'hui appellent
appel au dialogue donc à l'intérieur de
l'armée et du mouvement est aidée de la
classe politique même au sein de la
majorité mais surtout dans l'opposition
il serait d'accord pour nouer des
négociations un dialogue avec tous les
tchadiens que ça soit la classe
politique les mouvements syndicaux la
diaspora tchadienne en france donc on
voit bien que est ce que c'est une
vision vengeresse qu deux des fils mais
on voit bien que ce qui a été validée
même sur le plan international notamment
de la france sur ce
c'était un de transition ce chef d'état
qui n'est pas légitime peut regarder
droits fondamentaux des droits
internationaux droit international donc
il sait tout et et fouet ou pied alors
que le tchad comme l'afrique a besoin
d'institutions fortes et non des hommes
forts autocratique un chef de la
transition qui est soutenu par la france
puisque emmanuel macron enfin en tout
cas emmanuel macron fait déplacés au
tchad tout récemment c'est assez c'est
assez consternant
nous pensions que l'état français
notamment monsieur macron donc c'est
avec menu donc aller vers la fin de la
françafrique nom voit bien mais comment
parler de comment parler donc d'un g5
d'un g5 sahel qui qui travaille à une
meilleure gouvernance aussi en même
temps qu'un combat contre le contre le
terrorisme est adoubé une gouvernants
merci d'autocratie de 19,6 donc il ya
une incohérence totale et sa stupéfait
savait me consterne il pas seulement la
preuve des populations d'afrique mais
aussi les populations
française qui demande pourquoi au nom de
la république on soutient tel pouvoir
merci seller jean claude félix tchicaya
je rappelle que vous êtes chercheur un
lips fin